[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
from what I'm told sources close to me
six NFL executives are the ones who
create the NFL schedule and that group
includes our next guest he's Ani Bose
and the schedule makers get help from
technology thousands of computers
produce thousands of possible schedules
so that that leaves it up to the
schedule makers to select the best ones
and then I believe they pass it on to
the commissioner also you have to factor
in this
that part of the uh conversation the
tricky part is the networks will Lobby
to have certain games so the network
Executives always are angling to have
the best games on I don't know how
involved they are with any of those
things but that's why we're having Ani
boson Ani good to see you again NFL vice
president of broadcasting did I get
everything right there with uh behind
the scenes
I think you capture the essence Dan
great to be here with you um okay how
argumentative passionate does it get
behind the scenes with you guys before
you send it off to the commissioner with
these matchups it's a great question I
think you know the the good thing is as
you mentioned you know there's five or
six of us who sit in that room whether
it's a real room or a virtual room and
we're all really invested in this we're
all really passionate about making sure
that you know our objective is let's put
the best games into the best Windows
let's make sure our fans can see what's
out there the games that they're
circling on the calendar today and it
does get passionate because you've got
to balance you know kind of competitive
issues you want to make sure it's fair
for every team and how they play their
games but as you mentioned every Network
every Network you know wants and
deserves a piece of those top you know
40 50 games and it gets passionate where
you argue hey this game should be on a
Sunday night or this game should be on a
Monday or Thursday is this too big for
that window we're all invested in it we
all care it's it's all collegial but it
absolutely can get heated at times and
you know we walk out of the room at the
end of the day or at the end of the
process we all respect each other and
appreciate that we challenge each other
okay once you guys come up with the
schedule then you take it to
Commissioner Goodell
yeah I mean it's not as you know
straightforward as we walk in there with
hey boss here's the last one we've
actually over the last few years really
established a Cadence where we'll kind
of level set with him early in the
process that process can start as
immediately as after the day after the
season the previous season ends but we
really get into it once the Super Bowl
is over we know where the kickoff game
is going to be at the home of the the
champion and then it's iterative and
we'll meet with the commissioner
multiple times you know maybe once a
month in February and March and then
really through April probably weekly
we're up there giving them updates just
making sure that he has a sense of where
we're headed and making sure there's
nothing on there that he would say hey
don't do that or I would never play it
that way why Detroit against Kansas City
to open up the season it's rare to have
a team that didn't make the playoffs
last year
it's a great question Dan and that's one
of the ones that we probably had some
more of our more passionate discussions
about
um a couple things to factor in there
one when you start with the Kansas City
Chiefs and Patrick Mahomes any Super
Bowl champion is going to be attractive
but when you've got them in there you
know that game is going to have a high
amount of attention it's going to get a
lot of viewership he is you know kind of
our gold standard at this point of the
individual player that people are going
to tune in to watch they have great home
opponents this year they we could have
gone out with a Super Bowl rematch we
could have played Cincinnati the
championship rematch we could have
played Buffalo any one of those games
would have gotten Blockbuster numbers we
considered all of them they've got great
divisional matchups you know the AFC
West always matters the Chargers play
great Prime Time games against the
Chiefs so we left ourselves open-minded
there's a lot of years where we might
say this is the one game that we're
going to play on kickoff this year we
kind of said there's a lot of games we
let consider and as we went through the
process the lions were one of those
teams we left in there and we really
like that narrative around that team
they right you know as you well know
kind of what the culture that they're
building there the way they finish that
season you know eight wins out of their
last nine or ten games last time we saw
them on National Television was the last
game game 272 the regular season and
they were beating the Packers in Lambo
to keep Aaron Rodgers out of the
playoffs we really like that there's a
lot of energy there and we feel really
good about starting the season with that
energy against the Super Bowl champs
how much of the schedule is put into
place prior to the draft
and also with free agency or Aaron
Rodgers Lamar Jackson factoring in
rookie quarterbacks as well uh how much
does it change let's say after those
situations have been completed
look that question is really pertinent
for this year because the draft heading
into that week Aaron Rodgers hadn't been
formally traded Lamar Jackson hadn't
signed so those were in the back of our
heads right we were pretty confident
that Rogers was going to be a New York
Jet but we really wanted to see that
happen before we locked it in so the
fact that that trade did go through gave
us some relief because we had told
ourselves if he's not traded by Friday
Night of the draft we're going to have
to have some contingencies we didn't
have to go there
um beyond that you know the draft helps
us think about some things on the
margins obviously there's always the
handful of really high profile college
players Bryce young Stroud we're going
to look at those matchups and you know
you're going to see Carolina in a
national window and when we announce the
schedule tonight but you know it doesn't
overly change things but it lets us look
over those last two weeks okay here's
some interesting spots where these guys
may fall
and then Lamar Jackson re-signing does
how much did that change with Baltimore
and and are you guys included in any of
this does the commissioner say hey
schedule Baltimore I'm hearing that
Lamar Jackson's resigned like how much
information is exchanged when it comes
to putting this schedule together yeah
we're always looking for information
we're going to talk to our colleagues in
the building and what are you hearing
you think this deal is going to get done
it's always helps us to know those
things
um you know I think one with Lamar same
thing right you know they're a dynamic
exciting football team but it's another
level where he's in there so when we
were concerned hey there's a chance he
may not be on the team we may have
considered do we put Baltimore a few
fewer times into big windows on national
TV once he was signed full confidence to
go out there and put them in the windows
we have them in how many Prime Time
games for Aaron Rodgers this year
um you're going to see the the Jets in
the maximum number of you know whether
it's fully on prime time we've already
announced he's going to be in the first
uh the Jets are going to be in the first
Amazon Black Friday game so yes fully um
you will see them as distributed as
widely as you would have seen Aaron
Rodgers and the Packers distributed if
he was still on there but is is that 12
games
no there's a maximum number you know you
can make
um you can get be scheduled for six
National
appearancespn Amazon
um and then you know a certain number of
those games have to go to CBS some of
them are gonna end up on Fox as well and
then we just found out Sunday night is
going to be the Cowboys and the Giants
that's right we announced that this
morning uh wait oh you just scooped me
it's good it's the Cowboys and the
Giants on Sunday night just letting you
know Ani
thank you I appreciate that we do now
the Cowboys and the Niners
I'm stunned here Cowboys and the Niners
we announced in week five on NBC Sunday
night football yeah and we announced
that pick up as well and you didn't mess
up that that information is uh leaked
down just let you know I don't want you
I don't want you to get in trouble do
you like it I appreciate that all right
do you ever tell anybody like off the
Record you know somebody wants to know
hey I want to I want to plan my trip to
Miami see the Dolphins and the Jets uh
can you tell me when that's going to be
do you do you ever leak any information
uh sorted to the neighbors or friends
no um you get those questions a lot the
the easiest part of that is that up
until this past Monday those things were
all changing so I wasn't gonna you know
whenever I might have told you two weeks
ago may have changed by the final
schedule that we put in front of the
commissioner so that makes that job that
part of that a lot easier does the
commissioner have a favorite team
he loves all 32 equals no no no when he
no he doesn't he doesn't like Arizona
um it's hard to like Arizona this year
uh but growing up was he a Patriots fan
or Giants fan
you know what I don't know that answer I
think you should have him on and ask him
oh we've tried to Annie could you tell
him I said hello
I will for sure hey great to have you on
and uh good luck with uh the broadcast
coming up tonight
appreciate it Dan it's an exciting day
for all of us that's Ani Bose he's the
NFL vice president of broadcasting he's
been part of the NFL schedule making for
15 years now